a published report is identifying senior  presidential advisor Jared Kushner as  one of more than two dozen officials  whose security clearance denials were  overruled by a senior official  Washington Post reporting Kushner's  initial application was denied over  concerns about foreign influence private  business interest and personal conduct  Kushner is married of course to Ivanka  Trump Monday Kushner told Laura Ingraham  he is not a risk to national security  well I can't comment for the White  House's process but what I can say is  that over the last two years that I've  been here I've been accused of all  different types of things and all of  those things have turned out to be false  House Oversight Committee has voted to  issue subpoenas to try to learn more  about the clearance over rules